Bonjour à tous !
Aujourd'hui on va parler un peu d'informatique
et on va voir comment des règles très simples
peuvent parfois engendrer des comportements vraiment complexes.
Alors quand je dis "comportements complexes"
je ne parle pas de vous, derrière votre écran d'ordinateur, non.
On va parler d'une toute petite simulation informatique vraiment très étonnante
qu'on appelle " La fourmi de Langton".
La fourmi de Langton c'est un petit programme informatique
qui a été imaginé par un chercheur américain qui s'appelle Chris Langton.
Alors pour simuler la fourmi de Langton,
on va avoir besoin d'une grille :
dont les cases peuvent être blanches, ou noires.
Et puis on va imaginer que sur une des cases de la grille, on pose une petite fourmi
et que cette fourmi, elle va pouvoir se déplacer sur les différentes cases.
Les règles de déplacement de la fourmi sont extrêmement simples :
Elle se déplace en fonction de la couleur de la case sur laquelle elle se trouve.
Si elle est sur une case blanche, elle tourne à droite et avance,
et si elle est sur une case noire, elle tourne à gauche et avance.
Et on ajoute comme règle supplémentaire qu'au moment où elle quitte sa case, elle en inverse la couleur.
Donc je répète les règles : case blanche on va à droite, case noire on va à gauche
et dans tous les cas, on inverse la couleur de la case qu'on quitte.
Alors, on va voir ce que ça donne si on s'amuse à appliquer ces règles de déplacement de manière répétée.
Alors pour faire simple on va partir d'une grille qui est initialement complètement blanche
et puis on va mettre la fourmi au milieu.
Alors premier mouvement : la fourmi est sur une case blanche
donc elle va à droite,
et la case sur laquelle elle était devient noire.
On recommence, on est sur une case blanche, donc à droite
et on change la case où elle était.
A nouveau case blanche, à droite, et encore case blanche, à droite.
Jusqu'ici ce n'était pas très fun
mais là on est arrivé sur une case noire :
donc la fourmi va à gauche.
Ensuite case blanche : à droite, blanche : à droite et blanche : à droite.
Voilà, donc après huit mouvements
notre fourmi a changé quelques cases blanches en cases noires
et elle est revenue au centre de la grille.
Alors on peut voir ce que ça va donner si on continue d'appliquer ces règles de manière répétée.
Alors comme c'est un peu pénible à faire à la main, on va programmer tout ça.
Donc voici en accéléré ce qui se passe avec les premiers mouvements de la fourmi.
Vous voyez qu'en suivant les règles qu'on a donné,
notre fourmi se met à dessiner des jolis motifs.
Et puis voilà, je me suis arrêté à 96 mouvements
et vous voyez que la fourmi est à nouveau revenue au centre.
Voilà ! Mais maintenant qu'on à programmé ça,
on peut continuer à faire avancer notre fourmi
et regarder ce qui se passe si on va beaucoup plus loin.
Donc la fourmi reprend sa marche.
Et voilà ce qu'on observe, vous voyez qu'elle continue à dessiner des jolis motifs
plutôt symétriques [...]
[...] en fait ça ressemble un peu à des espèces de pétales de fleur.
Voilà, donc là je me suis arrêté à 472 mouvements
et on voit que la fourmi est revenue au centre de la grille.
Alors, elle a dessiné, tout au long, des jolis motifs symétriques
ce qui n'est pas très très surprenant parce que nos règles de départ sont quand même assez symétriques :
case blanche à droite, case noire à gauche, c'est quand même très simple
Sauf que...
est-ce que vous croyez que ça va vraiment continuer comme ça tout le temps ?
Et ben pour le voir on va faire la simulation en allant beaucoup plus loin
On va aller jusqu'à 2000 mouvements
Alors, pour que ça soit clair je vais dézoomer un petit peu
et puis je vais reprendre la simulation au début
Vous êtes prêt ? Allez on y va
Donc au début on a vu, la fourmi fait des jolis motifs symétriques
Et puis une fois passé les 500 premiers mouvements, on dirait qu'elle arrête
On a même l'impression qu'elle détruit complétement son joli dessin d'avant
Et on voit plus aucun motif symétrique qui apparaît
C'est bizarre non ?
Pendant les 500 premiers mouvements notre fourmi a fait des structures qui étaient très ordonnées
et puis soudainement on a l'impression qu'elle a perdu son sens de l'ordre et de l'esthétique
et qu'elle se met à faire des choses complètement désordonnées
Pourtant on a pas changé les règles de déplacement au milieu hein
ce sont les mêmes qu'au début
Bon alors peut-être qu'elle va finir par retomber sur ses pattes
et puis si on fait la simulation suffisamment loin elle va finir par reproduire à nouveau
des structures symétriques
Et ben pour le voir, on va simuler encore beaucoup plus loin
on va aller jusqu'à 10 000 mouvements
Alors je vais à nouveau dézoomer un petit peu
et puis on va reprendre au début, et puis passer tout ça en accéléré
Allez, on y va
Donc : motifs réguliers d'abord...
...là, on commence à faire de l'assymétrie
Mouais, puis visiblement la fourmi est devenue un petit peu barjo là
elle dessine n'importequoi
C'est plutôt le chaos total
C'est le chaos total alors que, tout à l'heure, je vous rappelle, on avait un truc bien ordonné
C'est quand même fou
Y'a eu commence une sorte de transition
Voilà
et puis ça continue...
Là on arrive vers 10 000 mouvements
Ah, et puis là il se passe un truc
C'est bizarre ! Vous avez vu ce qu'il s'est passé là ?
Attendez, je vous le remet un coup
Là tout à coup, sortant du chaos total, notre fourmi se met à construire une structure parfaitement régulière
Parfaitement droite
et qui se répète
à l'infini
Cette drôle de structure, on l'appelle : l'Autoroute
Evidemment, à partir de maintenant on peut continuer la simulation jusqu'à la fin des temps
il va rien se passer de nouveau hein
La fourmi va continuer à dessiner son autoroute, et ça va l'emmener jusqu'à l'infini
*petite musique oklm*
Bon donc je résume ce qu'on a :
On a une fourmi qui se déplace selon des règles qui sont absolument enfantines
Un gamin de 4 ans avec un papier et un crayon
pourrait simuler le comportement de la fourmi de Langton
Pendant les 500 premiers mouvements on a des jolies structures symétriques
régulières, bien ordonnées
Entre 500 et 10 000 c'est le chaos total
Et puis, à partir d'environ 10 000 mouvements
une structure complètement régulière : l'Autoroute
Alors qu'est-ce qu'il s'est passé ? Ca paraît quand même incroyable qu'un système aux règles de base aussi simples
puisse engendrer successivement 3 types de comportement aussi différents
Et ben... en fait personne comprend vraiment pourquoi
Alors, vous allez me dire : oui mais on est parti d'une grille complétement blanche
Qu'est-ce qu'il se passe si on part d'une grille dont certaines cases sont blanches et d'autres noires ?
Et ben, vous pouvez le faire
Et au bout d'un moment, pas forcément au bout du même temps,
on va toujours retomber sur l'Autoroute
En tout cas, personne n'a jamais trouvé de contrexemple
On aurait pu, par exemple, imaginer qu'il était possible de trouver des configurations
où la fourmi suive un chemin périodique,
où elle revienne toujours sur ses pas de la même manière
mais en fait non, ça n'existe pas
Alors, la seule chose qu'on aie réussi à démontrer
c'est que la trajectoire de la fourmi ne peut pas être bornée
C'est-à-dire que la fourmi va forcément à l'infini d'une manière ou d'une autre
Mais aujourd'hui personne n'a pu démontrer qu'elle y allait forcément en suivant l'Autoroute
Et alors, il y a même des gens qui se sont amusé à faire des variantes de la fourmi de Langton
où on utilise plus de 2 couleurs de case
Et ben même dans ces cas là, on finit toujours par produire des Autoroutes
Alors vous vous demandez peut-être pourquoi des gens sérieux, comme des chercheurs en math ou en informatique
s'amusent à étudier un truc comme la fourmi de Langton
Et ben parce que c'est un parfait exemple d'un système
dont les règles de bases sont très simples
mais dont les comportements sont très complexes
Et ce genre de situation
c'est-à-dire : règles simples au niveau élémentaire
et comportement complexe au niveau global
c'est quelque chose qu'on retrouve dans tout un tas de domaines de la science
Par exemple en physique statistique,
pour expliquer la manière dont certaines structures de la matière se produisent
Ou bien en biologie pour essayer d'expliquer comment des réactions chimiques
assez simples à la base
peuvent engendrer des choses aussi complexes que... nous
D'ailleurs Chris Langton avait initialement conçu sa fourmi
comme étant une sorte de système de vie artificielle
Vous savez, un peu dans l'esprit du jeu de la vie de Conway
dont il faudra que je vous parle un jour
Mais certaines de ces idées de : simplicité élémentaire - complexité globale
on les retrouve aussi dans les sciences humaines comme en sociologie ou en économie
Pour essayer de comprendre le comportement de groupes ou de foules
A partir du comportement de ses constituants élémentaires
Toutes ces idées constituent un nouveau domaine d'étude scientifique
qu'on appelle l'Emergence
L'Emergence c'est donc quelque chose qui est à l'interface entre les mathématiques, la physique,
l'informatique, la biologie et les sciences humaines
Et vous voyez que, même sur un système super simpliste comme la fourmi de Langton
on arrive pas à comprendre l'émergence de structures complexes
Alors je vous dit pas pour comprendre des phénomènes comme l'apparition la vie tel qu'on la connaît
Et donc les chercheurs qui travaillent sur ce domaine de l'Emergence
Ils cherchent à créer de nouveaux outils mathématiques et conceptuels
qui permettraient de comprendre ces phénomènes
Et... y'a un peu de boulot...
Merci d'avoir suivi cette vidéo !
Si elle vous a plus, n'hésitez pas à la partager comme d'habitude pour m'aider à faire connaître la chaîne
Vous pouvez me retrouver sur les réseaux sociaux : Facebook et Twitter
Vous pouvez me soutenir sur Tipee
Merci beaucoup à tous les tipers qui me soutiennent
Et puis vous pouvez aussi me retrouver sur mon blog Scienceétonnante
Merci, à bientôt
*petite musique oklm*
*chill*
*tmtc*